[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my question is
kind of acute
what does this mean for the nuclear
family moving forward
okay matt you want to take a stab at
that one since you've spent so much time
what a
fantastic job
too thank you all
so what is the uh what does the question
mean for the nuclear family or what
exactly are you asking
as we move forward what does like this
movement this pathway mean for the
nuclear family socially
yeah i think uh look the nuclear family
lies at the foundation of human
civilization and you know i i i think
for a long time we thought that was the
most basic thing that we had to fight
for and preserve was the nuclear family
but then we realized and a lot of us
over the last few years actually there's
something even more fundamental than
that which is the difference the
distinction the definitions of men and
women because if we if we don't know
that then we can't even have a family
um so i think that you know that's why
it's one of the reasons why this
question
um although it's uh it can be we can get
some funny answers out of people when we
ask it this is actually like the the
fate of human civilization actually
rests in a lot of ways on our ability
as a people to answer questions like
this
yeah ryan i say i get up every day to go
fight for five things faith family
freedom hope and opportunity
and if that is your filter if you get
the responses right
on that if you look at how
legislation that comes before us at the
federal level or some of these guys at
the state and local level and you think
about strengthening that family
then
many things are going to find
they're going to find a way to work
their way out
if you will many problems will work
their way out but it just shows you
the fight we're in to preserve that
family and to preserve that family
structure in our society
that was a better answer
make the answer
more succinct
henson county republican party
and
my question is
why do you think people get so angry
when you ask them what is a woman
i think there's there's two reactions
that we that we got
emotional reactions well well three i
mean there are some people you ask and
they were annoyed because it was such an
easy question why are you bothering them
with it like our friend don sucker
but for for the people that were stumped
by it it was either they were afraid or
they were or they were angry and i think
that's um a lot of the people that we
talked to just on the street and in the
film we only get a small fraction of the
people we talked to walking around the
street and you know for these various
towns
and what i picked up on was just a whole
lot of not so much anger from them but
fear they were just terrified and they
would tell us sometimes that well we
can't talk about this on camera because
our lives will be ruined it was the
anger really came from when we went to
the so-called experts like we went into
the halls of academia that's what people
got angry at us for asking and i think
the reason for that
is especially
our friend the professor is a great
example of this
is that he
you know the way that the relationship
is supposed to work as far as he's
concerned in the bubble where he lives
is that he just says things and then you
sit there slack-jawed nodding your head
and agreeing with whatever he says and
if you ask any question at all if you if
you show any skepticism at all to
anything that these people say
they uh they get very angry they take it
as a personal affront because that's not
the way this is supposed to work like
we're not actually supposed to be
answering any questions from your people
we're supposed to just talk and whether
what we're saying makes sense or not
you're supposed to simply accept it so i
think that's where a lot of the anger
what do you think justin
yeah i mean these guys are never
challenged you point out the professor
he's the classic example and as soon as
the conversation did not go exactly the
way he wanted it to it was just
uh
he just unraveled to it was amazing but
the real amazing thing that happened in
that particular interview was the fact
that matt was able to keep him in his
chair for another 45 minutes after he
unraveled so
uh matt definitely gets the award for
keeping people in the chair uh that
don't want to talk to him anymore for
the longest period of time
but yeah they're not challenged in
academia and and he
he was huffing and puffing when he left
he yelled at everybody and told us all
to put our masks on and um it was
amazing this guy should be pouring
coffee somewhere i mean he should be
with tennessee taxpayer dollars yeah
exactly he should be pouring people's
coffee and yet he holds this prestigious
chair position and and people mortgage
their homes to send their kids to this
college to hear this guy and what he has
to to say so hopefully if there's a
byproduct of this film it's not just
talking about this particular issue it's
people questioning if they really want
to send their kids to a place like that
i will say that i i do take a certain i
discovered i didn't know i was this
sadistic but i
do take a certain satisfaction in uh
knowing that these people are so
uncomfortable talking to me
and just forcing them to sit there with
me for even longer anyway i did quite
enjoy that
senator blackburn thank you for all that
you do and matt thank you amazing film
um
my name's todd um why is the left so
infuriated with puberty blockers they're
infatuated sorry infatuated with puberty
blockers and the accessibility to these
blockers for children
why puberty blocks are so important to
them is that what are they what do they
they do they allegedly as we heard in
the film they allegedly block puberty
which of course as we also heard is sort
of a it's a inaccurate euphemism because
you can't just
block it or halt it it's just you can
you can permanently damage the body
which is what they're doing but the
point is this is this is administered
before puberty sets in
which means that very young kids are
being targeted with this stuff
and
what they don't tell you is that
once they start the kid on the path
with drugs or even before that even
before we get to beauty blockers we got
the so-called social transition even the
simple act of the the parent saying oh
i'm gonna i'm gonna dress my
seven-year-old boy up as a girl and you
know then we're gonna switch pronouns
once that starts
they're now on a sort of conveyor belt
and almost all of them will stay on it
until they're fed right into the meat
grinder of um of mutilation and surgery
and everything else once they get on it
they're probably not getting off
and that's one of the reasons why it's
so important for for the people that are
advocates of this stuff to get to the
kids very very young
and one thing that came out in the film
also that i think we can't uh dismiss is
the the profit motive here you know
scott nugent talks about it there's
billions of dollars at stake and so you
have to think about it if you have a if
you have a
six-year-old boy
who's confused about his gender you know
you could just say to the boy oh no
you're a boy and that's that's what you
are and that's fine and that'll probably
be the end of it it's just like a phase
and he'll be fine but there's there's no
money in that right
but if if you say to the boy oh what
yeah you know you might actually be a
girl we should really think about this
now that boy is worth millions of
dollars
to big pharma the therapists the
psychiatrists the doctors the surgeons
down the line there's a lot of money in
i think that's part of the part of the
story and i think this goes back to the
first question the parental question um
by by putting these kids on these drugs
you're essentially taking control away
from the parents you're giving it to the
state you're giving it to the doctors
you're given to all the other powers
that are involved in this and it is
another way to to undermine the family
thank you uh thank you so much for doing
this and for having the screening
tonight thank you senator for doing this
my name is carrie and my question is
this oftentimes our cultural wars are
kind of a manifestation of what's going
on spiritually in people's mind i saw
some of the people that you interviewed
and i saw what i thought were symbols of
the occult
uh with respect to tattoos or some of
the things that might be on their
shelves as you were asking these
questions in and interviewing these
people did you have any sense at all
that that some of this goes deeper than
cultural that that maybe it really is
kind of a manifestation of what's going
on spiritually in these people's lives
or or just the spiritual wars that may
be in existence in society today
absolutely absolutely 100 that's uh we
we talked about after a lot of these
interviews just
the the the energy in the room sitting
with some of these people it's just you
could kind of feel this cold evil coming
from some of them um and it was very it
was very clear to me that there's there
is something deeper going on than just
people who are confused
and that also you know that's why some
of these conversations what are they
what do they devolve into almost
immediately well what is truth right and
that's and whose question was that in
scripture it was pontius pilate's
question in scripture and so
over and over again i felt like we were
talking to pontius pilate what is truth
what is truth exactly because what this
is
fundamentally is yeah it's an attack on
the family it's an attack on
man it's attacking women's tackle
children but even deeper than all that
is it's an attack on the very concept of
of truth of all kinds of truth moral
truth
uh you know
scientific truth all of it
and i think that's what lays at the at
the foundation of it
last point on that i i think you know if
we were to believe
that uh as humans as men and women that
we are created in god's image
this goes directly at that this is a
direct attack against that it's
convincing people no you're not made in
god's image actually actually you're
kind of a mistake but you you alone can
fix that and it sounds a lot like the
genesis story like no you have the
control to do this you can change it uh
and god has nothing to do with it so
yeah i think it's a it this this issue
in particular strikes me as a very very
direct attack at what's what's core in
all of us
hi uh the documentary was absolutely
amazing so thank you so much for letting
us come out and watch it
i was just wondering i think it's
completely remarkable that such a simple
question what is a woman can be
a huge stumper to some of these great
thinkers and
how exactly did you come across this
question and figure out that it was such
an amazing tactic to speak to some of
these people
yeah i think it was uh we actually went
back
on on twitter to find the first time i
asked it on twitter and i think it was
like i think it was something like 2017.
and uh and
i don't know what it was but it just
sort of occurred to me one day as i had
been talking about this this gender
issue for years before that
um
but it just occurred to me one day
there's just this really obvious thing
that's right in front of all of us
and uh the reason why it occurred to me
is i could just i was i don't remember
what interview i was listening
trying to say what do you identify as
and i just and i just wanted someone to
ask this person that question like what
what is that exactly to you what do you
mean by that and when uh when especially
when a child when a when a little boy
says i i think i'm a girl
what why aren't we asking the follow-up
question to the child of well what do
you what is a girl to you what do you
mean when you say that what are you
trying to say right
and um
it just
finally dawned on me that this is the
really obvious thing that we're all
overlooking which is which is an easy
thing to do because when you have an
attack
on fundamental truth
that that that attacks it you know
attacks something at such a fundamental
basis like that
it's sort of like
they're calling into questions things
that are so self-evident that you hadn't
even thought to think about them before
that's one of the reasons why i think
some of the people we talked to who were
stumped by the what is a woman question
like the people in africa at first were
kind of confused by the question not
because they didn't know what a woman
was but because it's so obvious they
hadn't even
stopped to think about it
and um
that's in some way the advantage that
the gender ideologues
have is just by kind of obfuscating and
confusing us
so that's where it came from when we
were uh working on questions sometimes
for hearings we will look at those
things that we think will end up
before the court and as i
visited with judge
jackson
preparing for her hearing i said when
you come to us at judiciary committee
i'm going to ask you about the school
board you survive
the woke kindergarten curriculum that is
taught i'm going to ask you about u.s
versus virginia with the vmi women in
military academies case and i'm going to
ask you about the ncaa allowing
biological males to compete against
biological females
and the reason for that and looking at
it from a legal
perspective
is because all of these issues will end
up at the supreme court and they will
have their say
on this
and i'm one of those i believe that
women's sports should be for women
i believe that
[Music]
that women should have
opportunities
that they should have these
opportunities that many times have only
been there
for men and i was talking with a
female skateboard champion
last week and she said we are fast
moving to the point that we're going to
have two sports
divisions not male and female
but male
and coed
and the opportunities to compete and win
and excel will be removed from women
i want to get to the question you asked
before the movie what do we do
when we walk out the door
and um
this question has actually landed
in
davidson county last week
at the
most prominent
women's
high school that my daughters went to my
wife went to
and they
asked the question what is a girl
and they decided that it means anyone
who identifies
as a girl
and
there is a firestorm going on
over that question right now
so my question is
as we walk out
what is your advice on the questions
that we should ask
on how we go forward
to
deal with this issue that is literally
the wave
that is crushing
us in so many ways as you've clearly
shown in your
yeah i would uh start a couple a few
thoughts obviously a big big question
and we were just justin and i were in
fact just talking about this earlier
today
um
where do we go next what do we do you
know in this movement
so a few things first of all on a
personal basis and this is not this is
not small this is actually really big
that one thing that we can all do
as as
rational human beings who recognize what
is true
and we see all this in the movie and we
know that it's insane
is that we could just live our lives
that way
like live
in the truth that you that you that we
all fundamentally recognize and and stop
tiptoeing around because that's what so
many of us have been doing that's how we
got to this point
that's the only way we could have gotten
here
you know the only way we could get to a
point where there's this pervasive
confusion about the basic facts of human
biology the only way it happens is if
like 95 of the people who know better
are too afraid to say it
and so the most important thing that we
can all do on an individual basis is
just be normal people
and and refuse to go along with any of
this part of that is someone says
um my preferred pronoun is this is what
i want you to call me
no i'm not gonna call you that okay
you're a man you're he that's it and and
i know people don't wanna you know we
don't hurt people's feelings and
everything else we are way past
having the luxury to worry about hurting
people's feelings okay because
civilization hangs in the balance i
really believe that
on so that's on a personal level
then we have to talk about well what do
we do on a grander scale and as far as
that goes i don't have all the answers
we're trying to work on that what i do
know is that there needs to be
a nationwide coordinated effort to stand
against this stuff right now there are
pockets of resistance of heroic people
who are standing up against this scott
nugent you know what people that are
around we ran into some of them in the
film but they're
they're disorganized they're just you
know kind of disjointed they're spread
all around they don't have a lot of
resources and support
what we need is something like the
pro-life movement which which for
decades was this
machine standing up
um and and having ultimate you know
enormous success standing up against the
butchering of children i think we need
something like that
to stand up against this form of
butchering children
um we need a national cohesive movement
against all this last thing i'll say i'm
going to stop filibustering sorry is um
there are clinics and children's
hospitals
in every state in the country
and i mean hundreds of them
where 13 year old girls are brought in
there and have their breasts chopped off
where little boys are brought in and are
sterilized and chemically castrated
and
there is nobody outside of any of these
places
holding a sign
or or doing anything about it you know
there should be protesters and and
picket signs outside of all of these
places all the time
but we need organization for that and so
i think that's got to be the next step
i'm going to come back to that but let's
get these last couple of questions you
all have been gracious with your time we
had more questions than we had thought
so let's get those in kind of a
lightning round and then we'll
finish up go ahead hi uh my question is
fairly simple um i am a christian and i
believe the bible is absolute truth
um you quoted pontius pilate who said
what is truth and judging from the
documentary you clearly won it
um matt when looking at the bible you
know i drive around nashville and i see
gay flags on almost every church's front
door how do you believe the church's
response should be to this agenda
according to the scriptures in this hour
okay let's wait until we get the next
question and then do this as a lightning
round
howdy howdy my name is taylor winston
and as a content strategist i wanted to
congratulate you guys on an amazing film
is absolutely remarkable
i'm a us veteran mass shooting survivor
2a advocate and a new father most
importantly
what kind of advice would you give to
someone as we enter this chapter of our
culture war
all right matt take it away for a one
minute answer only one minute okay all
right
uh
on as far as the churches go i mean what
can churches do one thing churches could
do is like anything at all you know it'd
be great if churches would just do
just do even the smallest little thing
and um
and then
to the question about you know as as a
parent i would say to me it's you know
there's there's a lot we need to be
doing as parents but one of the biggest
things
is please dear god keep keep your kids
off social media for as long as you
possibly can
and that's going to be a big help that
is true
and as we wrap up i just want to thank
all of you i think that right now as we
look at ways to protect our children and
protect our families that it is so
important to have people that are going
to be bold
that are going to speak out
that will stand for that
absolute truth
and not be fearful of that because i
fully believe that with this culture war
we are truly in a fight for the soul of
this nation so i thank you all for the
great work that you have done i thank
you all for the support that you give us
in the work that we do
and i thank you for caring about this
issue
and being here to protect
this country and be sure we remain the
greatest country on the face of the
earth thank you all so much good night
you